bonjour à tous votre équipe de tam-tam
canada légèrement réduite cette semaine
parce qu'il faut bien faire un
accommodement raisonnable pour les
vacances les vacances des eaux
aujourd'hui on va plonger vers un sujet
qui sans qu'ils respirent l'été
c'est-à-dire les baleines une véritable
safari
au niveau des baleines quand vous
offrent aux sur le fleuve saint-laurent
je vous dis là c'est pas des promesses
en l'air c'est pas de publicité de wal
mart c'est du sérieux c'est quelque
chose que radio canada international va
vous offrir aujourd'hui grâce aux
nouvelles technologies de communication
nous allons nous rendre sur place ici
même sur la grande place ce public de
rci en studio il y à marie claude simard
bonjour marie claude josse très fan
ouais mais c'est du côté français
webmestre du côté espagnol on a besoin
des espagnols toujours parce que des
français on n'est pas capable vous savez
il ya toujours et vous avez toujours
besoin de quelqu'un qui parle espagnol
léo gimeno de la section seconde zone
bonjour bonjour alors écoutez on parle
des baleines parce que bon ça ne passe
pas seulement l'été c'est pas le
prétexte c'est qu'il ya eu mort d mort
de baleines il ya deux semaines s'était
signalé il ya eu autopsie si baleine est
ce que vous avez est ce que quelqu'un
peut me donner des détails de ce qu'ils
ont entendu à la télévision à la radio
ce qu'il sait de baleine noire et donc
c'était dans le golfe du saint-laurent
je crois ben c'est ouais peu près d'un
gramme
si la laine ça peut sembler peu parce
que c'est un très grand nombre mais il
reste très peu d'années noires dans le
monde alors cesser ces tragédies 500
exactement alors bon là le top 6 se
poursuit s'est pas encore terminé on
pense qu'ils ont été deux des deux
d'entre elles ont été frappées
une autre a été attrapé dans un filet de
pêche on va vous parler aujourd'hui un
petit peu des ennuis des baleines et
surtout aujourd'hui on reste un peu un
surface c'est l'été si on va rester dans
le plaisir des découvertes des choses
autour de moi donc j'ai beaucoup de fils
d'appareils électriques et électroniques
parce que on en avait besoin
d'équipements supplémentaires
aujourd'hui nous avons pas je vous le
dis pas tout de suite ont invité spécial
d'accord oui
les baillis siens en studio elle est à
distance mais pour le moment pour
préparer la conversation on plonge 11
est vrai au niveau des images
oui on va monter dans un zodiac qui
amenait des touristes l'an dernier à peu
près ce moment ci d'année voir des
baleines dans le fjord du saguenay au
québec donc pas loin du grand fleuve
saint-laurent et ils ont vu un local
commun arrivés près d'eux mais regardez
bien la scène allez-y faites jouer des
l'image ça prend 30 secondes et dans
vingt secondes vous allez complètement
surpris voyez les bols de bananes
approché lentement le bateau appartient
à la compagnie à ml et se recale commun
tout d'un coup il n'avait 3 je pense un
d'entre eux a surgi et c'était des gens
payent ils plaident d'argent pour aller
voir ça ça 45 dollars 55 dollars
c'est pas fini un local
j'ai en moi je l'appelle gm texte un
recueil te tue rocade bébé regardez je
souris tout ça n'a pas de sens pour voir
comment les gens réagissent
est ce que ben oui on peut reposer en
paix les soigner là nous on est sourd
mais on n'a pas je n'avais pas accès au
sens nos internautes ont toutes les
hontes l'italie eux
alors parents d' écoute on va se rendre
entendre et voir une invitée spéciale
tout nous éviter son spécial rachel
brillait lavigne qui fait des croisés en
zodiac depuis plusieurs années avec
justement la compagnie à rl la voici la
voilà bon alors vous êtes tous en ce
moment vous êtes dans le bureau de ml ou
quoi situé nous situer les gens à
l'international à vous avez des
africains qui vous regardez ces housses
à tadoussac
si on dit de québec donc tadoussac se
trouve vraiment au début de la région
qu'on appelle la côte-nord manicouagan
donc sur les charmes scellera on a eu
juste à l'embouchure du fjord chercher
sur une carte le tabou se trouve là même
si on va pas voir les baleines cet été
juste aller dans ce coin-là du québec
c'est comme c'est un dépaysement certain
côte ouest canadienne
avez vous des questions pour notre
invité parce que c'est l expert des
baleines des croisières des visites en
zodiac ces petits bateaux là qui flotte
est ce que ça arrive souvent qu'une
baleine comme ça sur gesse en dessous du
bateau ce que c'est commun où c'est
vraiment exceptionnel qu'on vient de
voir la vidéo vous avez vu est vraiment
exceptionnel c'est quelque chose qui va
arriver plus tôt occasionnellement on
est souvent plusieurs navires a quitté
en croisière que ce soit les grands
bateaux ou les petits zodiac
donc on navigue au sein du parc marin du
saguenay saint laurent qui est une aire
marine protégée tout mêmes règles
concernant les baleines surtout celles
qui sont en voie de disparition comme le
biberon là bas les milieux mais il
certaines les baleines nous voient une
entente sous l'eau donc non on va
arriver sur un site d'observation où là
on fait presque du surplace et on
observe au taureau convoi percevront les
grands souffle on veut les entendre et
les baleines eux continuent de pratiquer
leur activité dvas killer application
tous les jours qui est principalement
l'alimentation elle rien on scellera
surtout pour manger et ça va arriver à
ce moment le sien navire un petit zodiac
fait du surplace si les moteurs éteints
ou au ralenti
la baleine à ce moment là où il peut
elle s'approcher et l'on va voir des
beaux spectacles comme celui auquel vous
avez celle sur les vidéos
leonardo d'une question dans quelle
partie de l'année qui sait montre plus
est ce qui vient manger toujours dans la
même époque c'est vraiment il faut avoir
de la chance pour me voir donc
excepté le béluga qui est résident à
l'année longue dans le slam c'est
laurent qui va effectuer des petites
migration depuis l'estuaire le sport la
région lukaku n'a jusque dans le golfe
saint laurent
toutes nos autres baleine arrive
directement dans l'océan atlantique où
elles vont passer l'hiver en général les
premières baleines voirie autour de
avril mais au printemps viennent passer
l'été donc durant l'été on en a toujours
de plus en plus qui arrivent par exemple
la baleine bleue est pas encore dans ce
secteur va arriver généralement plus au
mois de juillet
juillet-août et les dernières baleine a
piqué c'est souvent octobre-novembre y
en a même qui restent de plus en plus
tard dans l'automne jusqu'en décembre
ça c'est pour le changement climatique
changement climatique je m'avancerai pas
trop le plus c'est vraiment en fonction
de la distribution de la nourriture la
quantité de nourriture disponible dans
l'estuaire du saint-laurent le salaire
est vraiment le garde-manger le ces
populations de baleines qui vivent dans
l'océan atlantique nord ouest donc et
certaines qui vont migrer au large de
l'islande ou plutôt en norvège dans
l'eau froide très productive et on a un
très grand nombre plus d'une centaine
qui viennent vraiment dans le saint
laurent
le golf et le suave pour venir
s'alimenter dites moi vous pouvez penser
à notre client potentiel ici votre
client qui arrive hors d'europe qui a
payé son avion 1000 $ aller-retour et
qui veut absolument voir des baleines et
vient chez vous est ce qu'il va en voir
ou pas est-ce que c'est garanti
pratiquement tous les jours on va voir
des baleines salue pas une expérience
que vous recherchez aussi il ya des
croisières que j'ai fait récemment on a
vu une quinzaine de baleines dans toute
la journée mais c'était pratique et
principalement la baleine petit canon il
va on va croiser une ou deux espèces
d'autres feront dans une croisière on
peut croiser plusieurs espèces incluant
le rorqual commun qui était l'animal
vedette du vidéo vous allez présenter ou
la baleine à bosse mais des fois il va
s'agir d'individus pas respecté on peut
jamais prévoir à l'avancé
qu'est-ce qu'on va observer parce que
les baleines elles sont libres de se
déplacer où elles veulent c'est pas un
parc d'attractions oxymoron visite c'est
vraiment un environnement marées les
baleines ont un très très grand
territoire yam qui arrive de la gaspésie
pour venir nous voir
des fois ils vont séjourner une semaine
ils vont repartir c'est comme des
touristes à la recherche de nourriture
mais oui ya une garantie voir à chaque
croisière que ce soit une espèce ou
plusieurs espèces et palais que les
baleines paie aussi pour voir dit vous
êtes capitaine de bateau moi ou tout à
fait je suis vraiment guide naturaliste
une biologiste de formation qui a
commencé pour un email en 2013
et donc j'ai fait vraiment les
commentaires à bord des croisières japon
questions des passagers
et lorsqu'on aperçoit une baleine mais
je vais leur expliquer de quoi il s'agit
pour quelle raison il est ici puisqu'il
offre une présentation également de
l'environnement marin qu'on visite
puisqu'on est au sein du parc marin ne
faut pas négliger non plus le
saint-laurent me laisse faire les
dynamiques qu'on retrouve dans cet
environnement le qui amène les baleines
ici juste maintenant moi je fais la
présentation de la main j'ai eu un
capitaine qui m'accompagne qui lui
s'occupe de la sécurité
c'est la même chose moi je suis le
capitaine et puis ces deux là se sont
mêlés biologiste mais moi je suis je
suis en charge d'aider les populations
d'un espagnol as we du bateau oui avoue
fête de la pêche comme les basques à
l'époque d'accord quelle équipe et un
n'est ce pas écoutez est-ce que dernière
question avez vous déjà eu peur en
bateau en gardant les baptêmes quel type
de parents voulzy jamais eu peur c'est
sûr qu'ils aiment des journées comme
ailleurs où on a eu c'est peut-être très
mouvementée sur le saint-laurent
dépendamment des formes peut avoir il ya
vent de la vague
donc on va dire que ça brasse beaucoup
c'est vraiment une aventure des fois on
se faire mouiller mais on a des bateaux
très solide abords des grands navires
aussi c'est comme des grands navires de
croisière donc on met très confortable
donc non mais personnellement j'ai pas
une paire de low je suis comme un
poisson en fait et en général on a des
gens les visiteurs qui viennent nous
voir les passagers y en a qui sont
jamais allés sur l'eau mais on est
capable d'émettre à l'aise dès
l'embarquement du navire on leur parle
de sécurité à bord du navire avoir des
embarcations comment ça va se passer au
large puis concernant la présence des
balles m elles sont habitués à la
présence
elles viennent sur le faire une
alimentation chaque été et on est là on
les accompagne donc de voir une grande
baleine comme sur sa prochaine ce sera
pas nécessairement est effrayant c'est
plutôt excitant
je savais que le titanic a été coulé par
par une baleine tout le monde le sait
est gratuit et croyances comme ça que
les touristes véhicules des fossés des
histoires aux vêtements des légendes
urbaines et vous êtes obligé de démonter
la faire
moi ça m'est pas arrivé souvent ça peut
lui arriver souvent les questions qu'on
va le plus se faire poser si c'est
justement les risques de collision entre
une baleine et les navires sur les lieux
de croisière le pack marines y est la
voie maritime marchande saint laurent
qui passe au milieu on parle en croisant
des fonds de croiser plusieurs grandes
cargo de marchandises et là on va se
demander s'il ya des risques mais au
sein du parc you div
il ya des limites de vitesse comme on
aimait luis quand on est en présence de
billiger on fait souvent référence pour
une analogie comme si on était on est en
zone scolaire à ses millions d' approche
les baleines justement surtout
concernant belga puisque c'est une
population de disparition et si je peux
juste rajouté rapidement fonds croisière
en a même fait partie de l'alliance et
cobh allen qui est une sorte de
coalition entre les gestionnaires du
parc marin qui sont par canada et par
québec et trois autres compagnies de
croisières aux baleines sur le
saint-laurent et d'enseignement et tous
ensemble on travaille vraiment pratiquer
des activités éco responsable et de
conservation
donc en fait de l'éducation prénom
passagers on leur montre dans le fond
les bonnes pratiques
l'observation de baleines donc on ne
fait plus de cours sur de chasse à la
baleine quand on en aperçoit une même
une limite de vitesse à respecter
les ondes approche les distances
d'approcher le temps faim c'est aussi
auprès d'une baleine le tout mon but
justement de faire la conservation de
préserver de faire en sorte que nos
baleines que ce revenir et d'éviter les
accidents se font relativement rares et
souvent mais ça va mettre en confiance
les passagers nous le fait que choix une
absence - j'ai jamais ressenti de peur
de la part de collègues de passagers
nous on va faire peur à nos internautes
en quelques instants va leur montrer des
images la réalité ce que vous ne voulez
pas nous montrer par ce problème alors
rachel fantastique merci ça lui tout le
monde à ml
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à se mouvoir
et c'est pas fini parce que là c'est
sérieux on va leur faire peur ce que la
première vidéo c'était pas suffisant on
a une vidéo ce reste à g publié cette
semaine
vous êtes vous connaissent vous avez lu
l'histoire c'est écrit par raymond des
marteaux c'est hier je pense jeudi une
histoire qui se passe sur l'autre côtes
canadiennes la côte ouest et là c'était
des orques
alors attention les orks et des
carnivores fait près d'un an que je
pense pas qu'être sens puis je pense que
si un assaut draps quand même pas que ce
soit trop trop fort parce qu'elles ont
des regards dégâts des baigneurs qui
vont ceux qui se sont fait surprendre et
le langage est un peu crus attention
olala ça ne mange pas des gens ben non
mémoire du saumon alors entre ont
seulement un petit en bronze cette
grosse mais si c'est pour jouer c'est
ainsi que j'ai compris les cadets des
ddd jean marc peronne baleine hors cac
ça fait plus aussi à plusieurs années
que ça arrive pas c'est ce n'est pas des
hors cac qui marche déjà
non en fait ça va payer se passer
quelque chose à l'écouté pas fini on va
l'écouter des images ce sérieux des
dromes pour observer les épaulards au
large du canada
ça c'est une vidéo qu'on vous montre
c'est thierry deçà des archives de
radio-canada international sur la page
de tan tan cette semaine tomtom canada
tous y trouvent alors on regarde ça
c'est un jeu vous donne quelques détails
il y a les scientifiques utilisent les
drones que l'on qu'on peut acheter comme
ça en magasin mais aussi les pas ce
matin les militaires qui utilisent des
drones
il ya les scientifiques canadiens qui
sont mis à utiliser ça parce qu'ils
peuvent maintenant repérées on peut on
peut regarder ces images qui viennent de
noah
mais les américains et les canadiens
sont intimement associés l'un à l'autre
surtout sur la côte ouest canadienne
ils travaillent ensemble alors là on
voit des images de drones qui sont
utilisés notamment par des scientifiques
canadiens et là on peut repérer donc les
marques sur les animaux les blessures
les coupures et on identifie comme ça
l'est mais les bêtes plutôt que
d'essayer de l'état qu'est ce qui serait
un jeu peu dangereux et là les
scientifiques finissent par reconnaître
par par laure en leur donnant des noms
spécifiques c'est à regarder comme c'est
beau
[Musique]
saviez des images donc reproduite par
l'aquarium de vancouver
moi
et radio canada international a ajouté
son estampes là dessus comme des
opportunistes n'est ce pas
ah ça ça se passe sur la côte ouest
canadienne et on essaie de savoir
pourquoi ce que les baleines en groupe
c'est du suicide collectif
c'est très souvent on appelle cela du
sud moi je pense une vieille expression
mais des morts collective qui on essaie
de savoir pourquoi il y aurait des
plusieurs motifs pollution sonore qui
brise les communications entre eux qui
les cas ce qui donne des choses des prix
des moteurs par exemple ou encore
percussions avec les navires les filets
de pêche chez teraxion sur la page web
de tan tan canada on vous offre tout un
menu de choses sérieuses à découvrir sur
les baleines là bien sûr des missions
d'été on ne plongera pas trop profond
comme je les dires d'une émission mais
on vous invite à fouiller dans les
archives de radio-canada international
et maintenant on va on retourne sur la
côte est canadienne à terre-neuve
terre-neuve me semble que ce soit un bel
endroit pour observer des baleines en
observation mais juste pour cette
session la terre ferme
oui tout à fait puis
une personne résidant de l'endroit de
nous a dit vous devriez aller sur ce set
belobo loin de la capitale et puis on a
vu des baleines d'assez loin quand même
l'envoyer surtout lors leur jet oui mais
voilà alors ça c'est tiré d'un drone
utilisé par un scientifique canadien
nouveau et c'est donc pas des images que
vous avez tourné personnellement je
pense qu'être derrière la mama salle
devenant c'est une nageoire bon dieu et
on entend les oiseaux
donc si vos bacs c'est magnifique
puis on n'entend pas le drone c'est ça
c'est un détail important c'est la paix
c'est ça les vacances ces parties de la
ville quitter la ville s'il vous plaît
moi j'habite à la campagne c'est facile
mais si vous êtes prisonniers de la
ville d' c'est beau là on regarde sur
votre téléphone portable et même une
image ouais c'est ça quand les leaders
de life ça dure combien de temps cette
vidéo nous dit le dites le nous la
centrafique et l'image bon 3 minutes ou
3 minutes on laisse jouer
on laisse jouer parmi les sujets sérieux
qu'on traite cette semaine sale temps
pour les bélougas du fleuve saint
laurent
ils sont vraiment en difficulté s'il y
avait une espèce qui est en danger c'est
celle là celle issue du boutis ludiciel
et plus mignon sucré cash à loulle
et c'est pas carnivores comme les orques
c'est triste on va devoir quitter cette
image pour aller vers notre succès boeuf
de la semaine bah oui notre question la
bonne question
une question alors peut-être que nous
interrompt pourrait répondre maintenant
qu'on a mis la table
peut-être que pour amener les polymères
oui on aurait pu même la poser à notre
notre charmante et intervenante parce
que finalement on n'a pas eu de réponse
à notre question ça comme ça suivant
ouais alors la question en fait d'abord
on met en contexte déjà que les régions
maritimes du québec comptent parmi les
meilleurs endroits au monde pour
l'observation de baleines ce qui est
vrai je suis convaincu que ce pays j'y
raconte nord on envoie à fait aux
chaumes de l'argentine il ya aussi on en
droit pur fun navistar espagnol s'élève
à l'étranger mais l'essence etc et on
n'approche pas les pages les baleines
c'est vraiment dans la côte et on les
voit dans la mer c'est une mer houleuse
dans ce coin
ouais c'est pas comme au canada ou dans
un autre temps de la question était
pourquoi les baleines ou fascine-t-elle
autant bon mais parce qu'elles sont plus
grosses que nous alors là leur grandeur
grosseur à faire ce qu'il fait petit
mouvement pour nous c'est vraiment des
tonnes et des tonnes d'aidés chaque
niveau vous c'est ça vote servat fera
pas alors écoutez on prépare la
prochaine vidéo sur l'hymne national
canadien chanté par des bananes pendant
compris par ça à oui c'est
extraordinaire s'était produit l'an
dernier mais pas avant vous présenter ça
j'ai mon fameux jeu questionnaire de la
journée parce que j'ai pas oublier pensé
que j'avais oublié alors écoutez à quel
âge meurent les baleines au nom c'est
trop triste comme question je vous donne
la réponse suit 20 ans 50 ans et la wii
mais la voici une question est beaucoup
plus amusantes
attendez voir là une des plus grosses
baleines dans le fleuve saint-laurent
ses 100 ans anton quel est le poids de
la langue d'une de ces bases
lala hinton de temps deux tonnes
une tonne c'est quoi ces 1000 kg 1000 kg
de bon d'accord vous êtes six fois
éloigné de la bonne réponse de trois
fois éloigné de la boire
c'est 600 six lots pour bien oui puis on
a on a même une petite vidéo sur la page
web de tam-tam où on montre comment ils
ont expédié un coeur de baleines
je pense que c'était le fait enfin on a
tout son installation vidéo vous allez
voir les bleus ouais je vais pas vous
faire lever le coeur on a envoyé ce en
allemagne parce qu'ils sont en train de
transformer certains pièces de baleine
de les transformer en cire pour
l'épauler garder portes pour l'éternité
les yaks les allemands pour avoir des
idées comme celle là et on est prêt pour
l'hymne national canadien chanté par nos
baleines accueil haut niveau il valait
cent croient pas ah et puis ça commence
comme aline nationale du canada sur dix
au quiz
on écoute c'est beau
[Musique]
alors voilà ben joyeux anniversaire au
canada fait pardon que le ministère du
tourisme du newfoundland and labrador
donc terre-neuve et labrador petit jeu
questionnaire pour propre presque
terminée on a vu la baleine plongé tout
elles peuvent plonger par la combine
minutes sous l'eau sans respirer parce
qu'ils remontent à la surface respirer
c'est de jouer je dirais dix minutes
plus que ça commencer un débat aussi
long qu'une émission dans ta tête
oui plus que ça en moyenne 25 minutes
dont vous avez la bonne réponse mais ça
peut être le double jeu parce que si
c'est sa menace et menacer il va
plancher puis dernier jeu questionnaire
troisième on les enfile enfin vous faut
les baleines peuvent marcher
vrai ou faux les baleines peuvent
marcher mais si vous voulez des bruins
venaient si vous voulez démandé c'est
parce que c'est vrai
sinon l'avait pas demandé j'aurais j'ai
mal conjuguer mon affaire les baleines
pouvait marcher
il y à 50 millions d'années ont dit
qu'elles ressemblent à des chiens et
qu'elle vivait sur la terre et que se
sont mis à s'approcher de la mer je
pensais c'est l'inversé on est sortis de
l'eau pour ensuite marcher mais elle
sait le confrère aller voir les
recherches à ce sujet là alors ce sujet
là voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
ça finit le professeur n'y a pas de
tests c'est l'été dans capable est
merveilleux sujet ben oui c'est un beau
sujet ouais ouais moi je suis pour une
fois je pense que si on me dit que ce
soit faire cet été stéphane aller voir
et je pense que ça y est je découvre les
bateaux les gros bateaux par les papes
et on en voit vraiment beaucoup
alors je les aime mais de loin ou être
proche ça me fait même timide un petit
peu
je sais pas si la flatulence qui vont
tout faire pour ne pas dire autre chose
ça finit bien les missiles oui alors à
la prochaine merci beaucoup bail